انت بطني مشاعري كتير خوف غضب ليش يا ربي
انا طب انا كنت ست ولا عمري دخلت بمارس
الرياضه وزني مناسب امم حامله حمل طبيعي
مرضعه طبيعيه
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي رند البواب هلا عمري 49 سنه
دكتور نسائيه اكتشفت انه عندي سرطان وكنت
للاسف هذاك الوقت درجه ثالثه
[موسيقى]
سرطان الثدي مرتين مره قبل 14 سنه ومره
قبل 9 سنين وكان السرطان يعني هذا ما له
علاقه بالسرطان اول سرطان يعني جديد بس
هون كثير ساره بحب انوه على اهميه الكشف
في الموبايل
المراحل الاولى
مع احسن علاج
هرموني والحمد لله انهيت وهذا الحكي وانا
هلا ماشي
والحمد لله رب العالمين
خلق مني انسان جديده خلق مني انسانه صبوره
صرت اقدر كل شيء صغير بحياتنا ونحمد الله
عليه صرت اشوف قديش الصحه هي اهم شيء بكل
هالدنيا
الشيء الحلو الي اعطاني اياه السرطان هو
العمل التطوعي انا ما كنت اعرف ايش يعني
عمل تطوعي ما كنت اعرف شو يعني اعطي بدون
مقابل
كنت ادعي ربنا يا رب اشوف اولادي بس
يخلصوا مدارس
حلمي اكون في الصحه منيحه
يشفيني ويشفي كل حدا
اضلني مع عائلتي وانا بصحه مني
كمان اكثر
[موسيقى]
فخوره بحاله كثير فخوره اني قدرت اتحدى
مرضى كثير صعب
وبخوف
فخوره اني انا قدرت احكي على تجوبتي وقدرت
اطلع على كل وسائل الاعلام والتواصل
الاجتماعي واروح واحكي على تجربتي هذا
كثير ساعدني